the end of the coronavirus quarantine in
Japan is now adding new uncertainty to
the outbreak that started in China has
now spread around the world this morning
hundreds of passengers were allowed to
leave a cruise ship were more than 600
other people have gotten sick now that
includes 79 cases that were confirmed
just today more than 1800 people have
died from coronavirus illness nearly all
in China that's out of more than 73,000
confirmed cases
Deborah pata is at the port of Yokohama
Japan where that cruise ship docked more
than two weeks ago Deborah who are the
people getting off the ship well over
500 passengers have been left off the
diamond princess they tested negative
for the virus and more will follow in
the next few days there are still over
100 Americans either in hospitals or on
board the ship they've been banned from
entering the u.s. for 14 days after
their quarantine or hospitalization ends
Japan has been criticized by some
medical experts who say their quarantine
methods led to a further spread of the
virus that community health director dr.
Shigeru omie has documents from the
Ministry of Health's showing most of the
transmissions occurred before the
quarantine began there's sometimes one
day - there was something one week or
two weeks so should they not tasted
everyone
it takes six hours ob says it is a
dishonest disease because it's often
transmitted a symptomatically I could be
totally overwhelmed and wash my teeth
and scream and cuss and cry but wow if
that's really what it's gonna be then
that's what it's gonna be
Jerry Jorgensen from Utah is one such
patient hospitalized on Valentine's Day
she tested positive but has had none of
the symptoms of the virus already over
300 Americans on board the ship were
flown back to the US on Monday they are
in quarantine around the country to
prevent the spread of corona virus in
the u.s. like Cheryl and Paul molesky
who are at Lackland Air Force Base near
san and
no Texas CBS News spoke to them as
health officials from the CDC check
their condition the meniscus were
transported from Japan on a plane with
other evacuees some who were at a higher
risk for having the virus truly
nightmare so we were sitting with sick
people work behind their people or get
to the restroom now another cruise ship
the Westar Dam is raising alarm bells in
Cambodia after an American woman who
tested positive for the virus only after
she had disembarked they are still
around 200 Americans staying in hotels
in Pinal pain US officials are tracking
them and another hundred onboard that
ship
Tony Debra Paris for us in Japan Debra
thank you very much